speaking of indianapolis uh we're going
to go right to the mercedes-benz vans
phone line who's
joining us right now from nfl network uh
rachel banetta how are we doing rachel
hi guys good morning how are you did you
just like woo-woo your own introduction
well i mean
leaf gave me like a pretty mediocre
introduction like people like she's up
and coming
let's start
ready to start over let's start where's
the start over here now joining us on
the mercedes-benz vans phone line
amazing young talent in the nfl network
world met her on saturday at a
two-year-old's birthday party
clinging clinging to her dog she cares
for the dog so much
brought him to the party it was it was
an amazing introduction she joins the
show right now rachel how are you there
you go that's better that's what i'm
talking about hi guys happy to be here
thanks for having me on thank you thank
you for being with us um so you're in
indy first time to the combine we talked
about that on saturday and then
um
biggest thing for me is what what has it
been like for you you know first time to
the combine kind of watching what the
meat market looks like but what what
what has it meant to you so far
uh it's actually really cool i upon
arrival i have been warned by just about
everybody they're like stack up on your
fluids drink your liquid iv you're gonna
be drinking
alcoholic beverages a lot and so i'm
coming i landed on a red eye yesterday
i'm coming in i'm like okay tonight's
the night you know that our tv show
starts on thursday like we're going out
tonight
literally everybody
was gone i was bailed on by everybody
everybody was asleep by 10 p.m
and so i'm like okay i thought this was
gonna be a fun week this is where
everyone kind of gets to let loose after
the super bowl
everybody bailed on me i have no friends
here so that's my first impression um
and then just excited to see all of
these guys this is like
it you really can feel the excitement on
the street from these kids that are like
just walking around you see them
practicing their 40s in the hallways and
uh you know the bench presses there it's
it's a it is a really cool atmosphere
but you know like i said i have no
friends so it's going to be a lonely
week
we're speaking with rachel banetta nfl
network host benched with banetta
podcast as well um
all right so there's a lot of details
that go into something like this right
and things like hand size and arm length
and all these things i mean
being around the event and hearing kind
of the periphery of those types of
things how important is it for
for these guys to have these types of
things or is it just something that the
media makes a big speculation of
i mean i think it's fun to definitely
make you know hand sized absolutely the
most important thing of the day which is
happening as we should
as we should as we should you know we're
bored we have nothing else to do but um
no i this is like the biggest moment of
their careers thus far and i think that
you know they obviously want to excel in
like every single last bit of it i did
take the
now defunct wonderlic test yesterday and
like thank god that that has been ripped
to shreds because
i failed 9th grade math and doing this
wonderlic test i
i just felt like maybe the most dumbest
person that has ever existed so
what did i think did you get your score
sorry again did you get your score
um yeah i'm just a certified dumb person
that's that's actually what that's that
that was the result they were like don't
ever do this again what was that what
was the question that gave you the most
trouble on that though the question was
just like
a typical you know if the train leaves
the station at 3 45 it's it was just
like what what do these guys have to why
are they doing this there is no trains
in an nfl game well so there were many
times when ray lewis hit me i thought he
was a train i'm just there it was
blowing through there you have to figure
out what time he's leaving this station
to get to me at this station yeah so
it made some sense um
i was trying to think of some fun things
to do with you around uh
you know
you talked about the nightlife and you
were ready to do it and ready to go out
and you're young and i'm an indian the
first time let's see what it's all about
and then it kind of falls down because i
was kind of looking for some
superlatives if there was like uh you
know
most likely to succeed funniest things
like that um you know what what people
in our business either uh media wise or
do you think around the nfl would fit
into those roles
hmm
well this is the rich eisen show and i
don't know if he's gonna listen to this
but just you know just to suck up to him
he's the funniest and he's the best in
all of this relatives
um you know what's really
daniel jeremiah i would say most likely
to succeed i was talking to this guy
yesterday and just the way that his
his brain works like i was asking him
because he just knows so much about all
of these guys i was like how much room
do you have in your brain
like are do you have 150 guys absolutely
memorized is it 100 and he goes no i i
know every single thing
about all 300 something players at this
combine and it's just the practica he
literally started this prep
last year like at this time last year he
was looking at this class so
i think that um he's absolutely just
blown me away and then i would just say
rich eisen is the coolest and the
funniest and thank you for having me on
this show
uh so he wins all of the categories i i
like that i like that he's your he's
your your your peer there on on nfl
network and and of course you're putting
in a good two cents i'll just let it be
known that it was my idea to have rachel
on the show today everybody thank you i
i figured i figured yeah um
yeah
i like it rachel did you eat like 14
sausage biscuits also because that's
what ryan did
i did not no but ryan was the first
person as soon as i arrived he was like
let me run you through the snacks here's
where the cake is here's where the
chick-fil-a is he was he was kind of
just hovering over the snack table the
entire time which is um
a great place to be i'm a grazer
fighting off children he was like move
out of the way this is my donut
yeah i'm i'm a bit of a grazer at these
things um and
luckily uh sarah
tiana
mr brockman's fine partner and all this
cooked
the most amazing food and i just yeah i
i take advantage of those things also i
think i i think because uh i knew i was
gonna be on tv this week that i i was
you know kind of publicly shaming myself
i think that was the way i went i
approached things what um
what are you looking forward to
now that workouts start to begin what
are you looking forward to over the next
few days from the aspect of the combine
maybe
when it comes down to the players what
are you looking forward to most
um i think i mean i to be honest like
i've never really
experienced this before right um and i
think that this year is really cool that
they've added this whole new aspect of
like the fans are going to be right
there i think that there's been fans
before in the past but they've had to be
like way up in the in the rafters kind
of but they're kind of like allowed to
be close and and in the mix and also
they're blasting music
um so i'm excited to kind of just i can
only imagine i buckle under pressure i'm
not good at that stuff i can only
imagine how you know i it feels like
they're kind of trying to create the
atmosphere of like what an nfl stadium
would feel like and so
them just like running these 40s and
just feeling the vibe of like all of
these fans who are excited to watch
these guys i just think it's going to be
a really cool
energy in uh lucas oil and i'm just kind
of excited to to watch them do their
thing and also just like the craziest
thing is walking around and being like
oh this could be
we had this big meeting yesterday and
you and you know our our leader t-man
was kind of just like just remember
there's gonna be a hall of famer on this
field maybe maybe two maybe five so is
this kind of really cool to walk around
be like wow you never know who is gonna
like pop off and be
so insanely famous these guys lives are
just absolutely about to change so that
it just like
really adds to the exciting atmosphere
and um it's cool we got a kid on a bird
scooter yesterday and we were like get
off of there
oh neighbor what are you doing
it is so funny um you are exactly right
too because
it was so cold and sterilized
uh and and soundless when i was going
through the process many years ago and
how the nfl has developed this and they
can put them in a position because i
guarantee you the big reason why a lot
of these kids play uh is is because they
love the competition but they love to do
it and entertain in front of fans and
when you have fans there you have music
player and you have the idea of what
game day kind of feels like to compete
at that that can only generate i think
better statistics for these young men
and show them what they can do when the
lights are on
or it's like a sink or swim situation
you know they're already under so much
pressure like i have to run the fastest
i've ever run or i've i have to lift the
most weights that i've ever lifted and
like do it really well and then also you
add
the cameras on top of that and then you
add the fans in the stands and then you
add the music it's just like okay this
is
this is you know pretty close to what
you're gonna get for the real deal so
like who is gonna make it and who isn't
who can't who can rise to this occasion
and and who can't and i say that as
somebody ryan like i said i am not good
under pressure i would absolutely buckle
i'd run to the locker and be like you
know what i'm not cut out for this
what would be your best
young guys rachel what would be your
best combine event you know we see the
guys do the gauntlet
uh the 40 the broad jump the high jump
all that fun stuff what would be your a
plus event i
hm that's a good question i used to
throw up
um at track and field i don't know if
you guys have that in america like track
and field in like elementary school i
used to puke i'd get so nervous for the
race wow but then i'd race and i'd crush
it
out right now i know he usually runs the
40 at the combine i think he might be
doing it at the draft this year i could
totally
leave rich in the dust i'm quick i'm
nimble guys i'm speedy well he's also
very slow i mean he
he runs like a 605.
i was just gonna prove it i'm not here
to talk trash no no definitely talk
trash no definitely truck trash when you
see it yeah
yeah that's a big part about being in
this business
yeah i'm ready to prove it um and i
would argue that regardless of what you
say around you know when the bright
lights are on you're you're somebody who
stands in front of bright lights and
does commentary around things so you you
you don't fold under pressure let's just
make that very clear um
the idea
that they're making this more of a fun
event do you think it's
um the reason behind it is because it's
so stressful and so
uh pressurized have you have you gotten
that feeling just being around a little
bit that there's there's some very
serious uh a very serious nature to all
this because there's a ton of pressure
and there's a ton of stress but maybe
the nfl's trying to alleviate that a
little bit by making it feel like it's
more game-like and more fun
yeah i would hope so i mean all these
guys are really young and and of course
you know there's
these huge atmospheres in college
football like they it's it's not like
this is their first rodeo but it's
really scary and they're you know 20
years old or 21 or 19 or
you know whatever the ages are and it's
like
yeah this is the biggest day
of their life so for some guys it might
not get you know any bigger than this so
it's just like
let's take it easy on these kids this is
a game after all and so i just i think
watching it and going into this is like
purely like kind of just a fan because
i'm not
i'm no daniel jeremiah okay guys i'm not
a crunch numbers over here but just kind
of walking into it as a fan i'm like
this is really
kind of fun to see and like i said
you're watching these guys and you're
like
just if i was on the field
and thinking okay if i run fast right
now my life could absolutely change like
that's just so heavy
so i think that adding the music and
adding the fans really just kind of
creates a levity to the to the situation
and hopefully they'll be able to have
fun with it all right so let's play this
out we have all the events we know what
all the players do
what if there was a
broadcaster's combine
what are some of the what are some of
the events that uh like what would peter
king be best at
um
wordle
i like it yeah instead of the wonderlink
you have to do like you know 12 wordles
or something under 10 minutes i think
that that could work i'm actually going
to be a spoiler alert i'm doing um
the concourse combine
so because we have all of these fans so
into the mix and um
you know they are in the scans and
they're probably you know they're
probably talking to themselves like oh i
could
i could be faster than rich eisen or you
know um i'm going to put some of these
guys to the test we are going to be
asking them wonderly questions so i'm
really just on the lookout for it to
make fans look dumb which i think will
be very entertaining to watch on
television uh
and
so that is something that i'm absolutely
going to do but it would be really funny
to actually put
some of these analysts through the
actual combine drills which we
absolutely should do so that you can
kind of see
this is what an athlete looks like this
is what rachel banetta looks like when
she's trying to lift weights
you're doing a great job for teasing our
next uh few segments here we're going to
do a little comparison
around some of these combine individuals
and whether or not people would think
that they are are the can't miss
prospects so thank you for for being a
part of the show this morning and being
there for the first time and filling us
in rachel banetta everybody from the nfl
network thanks rachel thank you guys for
having me
this is fun have fun go to shake shack
rachel banetta she we got double whoops
from her to open to close you know i
think that you know she inspires me so
if i go on shows from now on and get
introduced she's going to whoop yourself
i'm i'm my my own hype man
is essentially who she is she's her own
hype man hey if not you then who right
right you know what i mean yeah not me
then who hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here